So last night we had the third Democratic
presidential debate.
This one with 10 candidates total instead
of 10
and that it's across two nights happened on
just one night and this was actually in just
about every sense, the best debate so far
and I'll tell you who I think did well.
I'll tell you what I think the impact of it
will be, but as far as the debate goes, yes,
the ABC, Univision moderators still asked
cartoonishly stupid questions, which I will
discuss, but I had sort of complained on Twitter
three hours.
Do we really need three hours of debate, particularly
when it, most of these 25 minutes go by before
the first question is you and ask between
sports like introductions and an immediate
commercial break and a video montage and opening
statements.
You don't get to the first question very often
until nearly 30 minutes in.
They didn't do that.
They started with the first question very,
very quickly or at least opening statements.
It ended actually like 20 minutes shy of the
three hour mark and in the end all the other
debates had gone long.
This one went short and was far more substantive.
They spent, I think it was the first, uh,
30 to 35 minutes of questions I'm going from
memory here was just healthcare.
Did we learn an insane amount about everybody's
health care plans?
Maybe not.
But what did happen, and this is the whole
point, when you spend more time on one topic,
even when it is 10 people on the stage, which
is a whole other problem, even if you don't
get that much more detail from most people
about their plans, it starts to become clear
who has nothing more than just two or three
bullet points about what they would do.
Joe Biden starting to stumble about the dynamics
of if you can't afford it or if you can't
afford it or whatever else the case may be.
Elizabeth Warren, who had been accused of
backing off of Medicare for all, at least
in rhetoric during yesterday's debate, coming
back fully and saying Medicare for all is
the way, uh, various doodly rebutting this
idea that taxes would go up by saying very
clearly.
Yeah.
But who cares if taxes go up, the total cost
goes down because you don't have premiums
and copays and all of this other stuff.
Um, let's talk about some of the different,
uh, elements of this that I think will impact
it overall.
Let me get out of the way.
The moderators did a better job than in many
previous debates and by focusing longer periods
of time on one issue, they were playing a
role of furthering depth on some topics including
climate change and health care, et cetera.
But there was still no shortage of completely
ridiculous questions.
At one point, asking Bernie Sanders to say,
uh, hey kid, you're, you're a socialist and
Nicolas Maduro in Venezuela is a socialist.
Uh, what do you make of that?
And then Bernie Sanders having to explain
different types of socialism.
This actually, I set it on Twitter and some
people agreed with me, some people went after
me.
Bernie's policy.
If Bernie is a democratic socialist privately,
okay, maybe he is Bernie's policies or social
democratic policies in line with capitalist
countries in northern Europe that are well-regulated
and use the fruits of the capitalist system
to disproportionately help the least among
us.
That's Bernie's policy and this is one of
those things where I've been saying it for
years at this point and like 75% of my audience
is with me, 25 is not.
Um, if he all along just said, uh, I considered
myself a democratic socialist in my youth
or whatever and not even mentioned that I'm
a social democrat.
My policies are in line with countries that
are capitalist countries, Nicolas Maduro and
that form of Pho populist, so-called socialism,
whatever.
It has nothing to do with what I'm doing.
And to even suggest the comparison is absolutely
absurd.
He can't do that because he does call himself
a socialist and then he has to make finer
distinctions, whatever the question was ridiculous,
didn't further our understanding at all of
a Bernie Sanders platform.
They asked Corey Booker about is he gonna
push his Vegan Diet on everyone?
I'm paraphrasing here just ridiculously stupid
question, but potentially a missed opportunity
for Cory booker where he could've talked about
animal welfare.
He could have talked about the importance
of diet.
I mean he could've been humanizing in self
humanizing in some way and it ended up just
being a stupid question and kind of a non-answer.
Now one of the bigger narratives that I was
paying attention to, which is a real narrative,
unlike corporate media, often foments totally
bogus narratives.
Nobody cares about.
I think it was before the second debate.
CNN was pushing what will happen when booted,
judge and O'Rourke go against each other.
It's like nothing.
No one cares about that.
They're each polling 2% totally fabricated
narrative.
There was a real question yesterday.
They were really two primary questions for
me.
Number one, how to what degree would Bernie
and Warren who are the two progressive front
runners, Biden, of course, being more of a
center left front runner.
Would Bernie and Warren start to go against
each other to any degree to try to distinguish
themselves from each other, often just being
lumped together as the two progressive's.
The other question was would Bernie and Warren
either together or separately start to go
after Joe Biden now that he is sort of within
striking range?
And the answer was Bernie went against Biden
way harder than Warren and I, I may just not
be remembering, but I don't really remember
Warren going after Biden at all, may be one
sort of lightly.
But Bernie went after Biden on the Iraq war
vote.
Bernie went after Biden on healthcare, and
some of those moments were arguably Bernie's
best moments.
Now.
What did not go so well for Bernie?
He unfortunately either had some kind of bronchitis
or was just horse from so many events, but
he had like a half lost voice.
He didn't lose his voice, but particularly
the first half of the debate, his voice was
not strong.
And by sheer you could say it's chance or
if you're more conspiratorial, you could say
it's because ABC wanted to help Elizabeth
Warren very often.
Both Bernie and Warren would rebut what Joe
Biden would say, but it would almost always
be Elizabeth Warren who got the first opportunity.
And as I've said before, even though they
come from different political backgrounds,
Bernie and Warren end up very similar on policy
and thus their rebuttals to Joe Biden were
very, very similar and merely by virtue of
Elizabeth Warren getting the first rebuttal
against Biden and Bernie Sanders getting the
second rebuttal, which often contained a 90%
the same substance and Bernie had half lost
his voice.
I think the optics were much stronger for
Elizabeth Warren in terms of giving her perspective
even though as I said, she didn't really attack
Biden in the way that, uh, some thought maybe
she would be doing.
Uh, one thing that became very clear, and
again this is uh, this is why we want more
depth and I would want way more with fewer
candidates on stage.
When you spend 40 minutes on one topic and
uh, you actually are put in a position where
you have to go seventh and explain what is
your policy one dead giveaway that you don't
really have a policy that's unique in any
way is when the candidate would be asked,
like the sixth person would say, okay, what
is your position on what should happen with
trade?
And they just talk about how Trump is doing
things that are bad and restate very general
principles on trade.
This became very, very transparent, uh, with
a number of different candidates.
There was no, you know, Camila Harris on trade
had nothing unique or irrelevant to say she
criticized Trump.
It's like you're running against each other
to go against Trump.
You're, you all disagree with Trump.
I would limit the amount that you're attacking
Trump at this point in the third debate and
had nothing particularly interesting to talk
about.
Uh, with regard to trade, there were a lot
of examples of this, a strong moment for Beto
or Rourke was when he was asked, are you going
to just confiscate AK 47 and ar fifteens or
what are you going to do?
And it was sort of a right wing framing of
the gun question.
But I respect Beto for saying yes we are,
we are going to confiscate them.
Other countries have done it.
What's going on here is a disaster.
We are going to confiscate some of those really
deadly weapons.
The pro gun crowd is going to hate it.
Either way.
The pro gun crowd is going to say that the
entire debate was filled with people that
want to grab guns even if they don't say it,
even if you don't agree with the policy.
I actually respect Beto for saying it.
Uh, Andrew Yang had his best debate by far
and I got a lot of emails from Yang Gang people
who felt that he didn't do so well.
I think he actually did, did uh, his best
where he suffered his, he's almost too polite
and he will stop short of his full time rather
than going over it.
And this was one of the reasons why his speaking
time was low.
Also, they just don't go to him nearly as
often.
He made a joke at the beginning of when talking
about healthcare, about I'm Asian, so I know
a lot of doctors or something like that.
And I actually do find it funny when he says
stuff like that when he says, I'm the opposite
of Trump.
I'm an Asian guy who likes math or whatever.
I don't know if it actually endears him a
two people or if it's just kind of a thing.
You hear a candidate say, we're, we're, it
feels like he's there trying to get attention.
I'm sort of blind to it because I'm so sucked
into this stuff.
So I'd be curious what you think about that.
On speaking time, Biden and Warren got the
most followed by booker then Bernie Kama Harris
Mayor Pete Castro club.
Machar Beto and Yang would the least speaking
time.
Not surprisingly.
Overall, I believe Elizabeth, I don't know
who won it.
It was less clear in this case.
I think Elizabeth Warren did really well.
I think, uh, Andrew Yang had his best debates
so far, who Leon Castro was very strong on
a number of issues including immigration and
criminal justice reform.
Senator Bernie Sanders was strong, said the
right things, but again, was diminished with
the horse voice.
And by virtue of having to go second after
Warren in a lot of the rebuttals.
But those are the four that I think did the
best.
Some people on Twitter yesterday were saying
Kamala Harris crushed it.
I don't know.
I don't know what debate you watched.
I didn't see Kamala Harris crush anything.
But in the end, I don't expect big polling
moves other than maybe within the top three.
And the reason why is Warren Biden and Bernie
have substantive records on policy beyond
everybody else on stage.
They have preexisting basis of support.
They have a sort of different visions generally
about how they would govern.
And they have constituencies that just don't
really allow that much room for other candidates.
So quite frankly, there's not that much support
for the other candidates to gain because the
top three now have solid basis of support.
Uh, we will see how the polls change between
now and the fourth debate, which will be again,
a two night thing with 11 candidates October
15th and 16th.
I think it is a mistake to be adding more
candidates.
We should be calling them even more.
But alas, that is not the case.
Warren Castro, Yang Bernie, not in any particular
order.
The winners of last night's debate
agree with me.
Disagree.
Let me know.
I'm
on
twitter@impactthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com